et c'est l'heure de partir à la chasse
aux enfants que ce avec vous antoine
fenaux antoine bonsoir à coeur au menu
ce soir une marque française ciblé par
une fausse vidéo absolument clair et
cette marque c'est chanel le couturier
de luxe qui a été donc la cible d'une
fausse vidéo très réaliste que je vais
vous montrer la voie si une vidéo vous
le voyez qu'il reprend la charte
graphique on l'aperçoit nos confrères du
figaro de leur section internet on y
voit donc les logos présents sur les
devantures des boutiques chanel taguée
avec les fidji vous le voyez à d'adolphe
hitler la justification est bien une
allusion on voit ici dans ce tweet soit
disant oh un scandale visant les clients
russes de la marque star on va y revenir
un peu plus tard cette vidéo elle a été
partagée notamment par l'influencé russe
victoria bogna vous la voyez ici son
compte instagram on a fait une capture
ici info ou intox car la publication a
été supprimée là encore on va y revenir
on va s'expliquer là dessus la qualité
du montage de la vidéo à d'ailleurs
interrogé les internautes qui se
demandaient ce que le figaro a adhéré
céderait vraiment publier cette vidéo
est bien le figaro a répondu sur son fil
twitter vous l'apercevez ici c'est une
publication fallacieuse dit le compte
officiel du journal qui détourne donc
notre charte graphique est basé sur un
photomontage voilà donc pour la fosse la
vidéo fausse de boutons ou en revanche
le doute subsiste clair sur ces photos
que vous avez aperçu dans cette vidéo
des clichés des deux aventures elles ont
également hélas est largement circulé
sur twitter on en voit ici un exemple
cet internaute donc les relais et
dénonce la politique de cette grande
marque contre les clients aux russes
mais on va y envoyer là encore il
revenir mais d'abord ces photos elle
semble représenter vous voyez plusieurs
boutiques chanel parisienne notamment
voici un exemple qu'on a retrouvé ici
sur google m'a bourré salaire de de
coller avec les photos qu'on a vu un
petit peu avant notamment celles que
vous voyez ici en bas à gauche en
revanche ici à info ou intox et aux
observateurs on n'a pas pu déterminer
avec précision s'il s'agissait d'un
photomontage ou si ces photos existent
vraiment et qu'elles ont été détournés
de leurs lors de leur objet initial ça
c'était pour la forme mais le fond alors
à quoi ces photos et cette vidéo font
référence et oui c'est toute la question
alors ces photos et déjà pour la petite
histoire le font leur apparition le 7
avril ce conte télégramme que vous
apercevez ici il est issu du média russe
indépendant il faut le préciser qui
s'appelle le bazar où l'on voit ici en
revanche elles apparaissent aussi à la
même date la enr sur d'autres chaînes
télégramme beaucoup plus pro
gouvernemental c'est notamment le cas de
cette chaîne télégramme baptisé rite
vodka elles font référence aux sanction
vous savez adopté par l'union européenne
qui de fournir de vendre des produits de
luxe à toute personne physique ou morale
aux us si l'article est bien dépasse les
300 euros un ressortissant russe et bien
c'est simple ne peut pas les acheter de
quoi provoquer et c'est assez savoureux
quand même la colère des influences
heuzé autre personnalité très aisé russe
à dubaï certains et certaines n'ont pas
pu vous se voir vendre un sac de quoi
provoquer un scandale diplomatique vous
l'imaginez ma chère clair l on tire y
est évidemment très très difficile on
l'est on compatit elles ont crié au
racisme évidemment et à la russophobie
voir et là c'est peut-être un peu plus
intéressante étant la marque de nazis et
il faut dire que sur ce point eh bien
elles n'ont pas tout à fait tort car les
historiens ont en effet démontré on en
avait fait d'ailleurs un article ici à
france 24 vous voyez un exemple notre
site francophone que coco chanel la
créatrice de la marque a été pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale est bien un
agent du renseignement du troisième
reich c'est vrai il faut le dire une
collaboration intéressés on nous nous à
nous en nous apprennent les historiens
car en fait coco chanel espérait ainsi
récupérer vous savez la propriété de sa
marque de parfums dont l'emblématique
numéro 5 une branche détenu par une
famille juive à l'époque donc vous le
voyez des sanctions occidentales qui
passe mal une fausse vidéo crédible et
des accusations de nazisme cela recettes
pas très très savoureuse du nain fox à
tiroirs vous l'aurez compris merci
beaucoup antoine fnaut peut retrouver à
votre chronique bien sûr sur notre site
internet
www.francebillet.com nôtre